ein licht am ende des tunnels für die
friseure und für alle anderen bleibt es
zappenduster erstmal wie geht es ihnen
wie geht es den menschen die vom
lockdown betroffen sind das wollen wir
besprechen das wollen wir diskutieren
uns zugeschaltet heute abend sind oder
weil sie ist friseurmeisterin aus köln
wird oguzhan aus stuttgart und rené
lehmann er ist besitzer eines
brautmodengeschäft in hamburg herzlichen
guten abend ihnen allen die frau da
silva sie sind die einzige die jubeln
kann wie geht es ihnen welche aussicht
haben sie jetzt auf die nächsten wochen
im märz darf es wieder losgehen
das müssen gute nachrichten für sie sein
ich habe mich gestern riesig gefreut
und ja und jetzt müssen wir die ärmel
hochkrempeln und die themen bücher sind
jetzt schon voll und wir können endlich
los gelegen
und sie entscheiden und herr lehmann was
es ihnen durch den kopf gegangen als sie
gehört haben dass die endlos lockdown
schleife weitergeht ich mag mir gar
nicht vorstellen ehrlich gesagt wie sie
sich gefühlt haben
also bei uns ist eine katastrophe also
ich glaube da ich dann da gab gar nicht
sehen kein licht sehen kann lichtlein
sehen gar nichts sehen wir sind richtig
richtig getroffen um die
perspektivlosigkeit macht einen richtig
zu schaffen
man kann gar nichts planen man kann den
mitarbeitern keine hoffnungen geben
ich habe einen koch deren baby hat der
gerade eine wohnung sucht weil er
gastronomisch kriegt er keine wohnung
also in sogar der vermieter hat auch
recht ich als vermieter auch keine
wohnung geben also die
perspektivlosigkeit in der tat ist es
ist es ist eine richtig es ist ein
alptraum
also ich bin nicht jammern ja also gott
sei dank jetzt nicht so richtig schlecht
dass wir jetzt nicht zum essen haben
aber perspektivlosigkeit man öffnest du
ein restaurant
wann kriegt der mitarbeiter seien voll
und ich habe meine mitarbeiter als
arbeitgeberzuschuss jeden monat versucht
den vollen lohn zu geben weil die babys
zu hause haben
ich habe aus meiner tasche bezahlt ja
und was soll ich noch machen ich war
was man da machen muss ich bin seit 15
jahren selbstständig ich will einfach
eine perspektive ich will wissen in
welche richtung gehen wie herr lehmann
sie nickten es ich nehme an es geht
ihnen jetzt in dieser krise sie haben
ein brautmodengeschäft sie sind seit
dezember geschlossen ist wird ihnen
wahrscheinlich nicht sehr viel anders
gehen als chf 1 dass eben gerade
beschrieben hat uns geht es ja sogar
noch schlimmer unserer ganzen branche
bei uns geht es nicht nur darum dass wir
brautkleider verkaufen sondern unsere
ganze branche sind ja viel mehr leute
auch die hochzeit für fünf bisher der
flur ist der dj der fotograf alle die
haben ja seit monaten überhaupt keine
aufträge eine braut klar sie kann feiern
aber mal ehrlich macht man noch zwei
eier mit 20 gästen macht man auch nicht
und diese ganzen lockerungen wie man sie
ja so schön nennt ganz im ernst die sind
die konferenzen nicht wert auf dem sie
beschlossen werden es ist einfach für
uns alle eine verarschung hoch drei und
wenn man mal ganz ehrlich sind corona
verwirrt sich doch in zukunft wie eine
krippe verhalten das kommt auch jedes
jahr wieder
und warum soll auf einmal dass gronau -
verschwinden es wird neue mutationen
leben die werden jedes jahr wiederkommen
und ich muss mich auch hier
wahrscheinlich immer wieder impfen
lassen wenn man sich dann impfen lassen
will
also wie machen wir das jetzt drei
monate auf neun monate geschlossen
wieder drei monate auch wenn wir jetzt
den incidents wert von 35 haben aber ich
dann eine woche auf war dann am nächsten
tag 36 ist habe ich wieder geschlossen
wie sollen wir das machen und auch wir
wir müssen jetzt gucken wir haben auch
brauchte termine richtig voll in unserem
buch eigentlich viele verschiedene die
termine komplett raus machen nur noch
donnerstags kleid habe ich im schrank
passt schon manche bestellen ihr kleid
aus china für 100 euro sind total
entsetzt was wir denken dann endlich
nach hause geliefert bekommt die ist
traurig das funktioniert einfach alles
nicht und unsere branche lebt von der
persönlichen beratung im laden und jetzt
nichts gegen friseur ich finde das super
dass die wieder aufmachen dürfen
wenigsten etwas wir müssen ja alle auch
mal gut aussehen aber wenn ein hört
schon sagt wir müssen die würde den
menschen wieder zurückgeben haben sie
unter die würde genommen und steht nicht
im grundgesetz die würde des menschen
ist unantastbar
passt doch auch ohne frau dass sie haben
geradezu gehört sie sind ja jetzt die
einzige die öffnen dürfen und es stößt
auf ja also natürlich mein gönnt ist
ihnen aber es stimmt natürlich auch auf
verzweiflung bei den menschen die jetzt
nicht aufmachen dürfen können sie das
ein punkt weit verstehen warum er dürfen
die friseure aufmachen und warum müssen
die anderen weiterhin geschlossen halten
ist total gut verstehen ja dass man da
das ja das auch gerne für sich hätte
also ich glaube auf jeden fall dass der
friseur vielleicht auch gerade auch bei
älteren menschen nur da überhaupt dazu
beiträgt dass man sich halt auch in
dieser super schwierigen zeit wo man
eigentlich ja so gar nichts darf oder
kann zumindest sich wohlzufühlen halt ja
und ich glaube schon dass das ein sehr
wichtiger faktor ist der moment wo man
eben nichts anderes machen kann für sich
was sagen sie sagt ich möchte die frau
es aber auch nicht angreifen ich bin
froh wieder hübsch gestaltete menschen
zu sich und die tief weil laub mehr alle
last und sauber oben und alle gesichter
sind einfach nur nach deprimiert
definitiv aber jetzt wieder nicht
angegriffen fühlen bitte aber wir
brauchten berater wir machen eine eins
zu eins beratung es heißt wir hätten
theoretisch und viel viel weniger
kontakt als ein friseur
wir haben kollegen da sitzt eine andere
kundin die haben keine ahnung wie das
jetzt bei euch sein wird 50 leute am tag
pro stunde ich weiß es nicht und bei uns
ist es ja so wir arbeiten mit termin nur
die braut ist da und nur ich als berater
sind da mit maske im anderen drohen dran
also wir sind ein nischen produkt und
genauso wie wir gibt es bestimmt auch
ganz viele anderen leben geschäfte
selbstständige die als nischenprodukt
auch so beraten können ein küchen
verkäufer der darf die ganze zeit weiter
verkaufen und da kann man sich termine
buchen
warum nicht auch in solchen produkten
wir sind verzweifelt wir können nicht
mehr
ich bin existent seit ungefähr zwei
jahren mit meiner kleinen boutique ich
muss pro quartal 5000 euro für den
kredit zurückzahlen
wie denn weil die korona helfen da fängt
ja auch schon wieder an
es werden ja nur 90 prozent von den fix
kosten erstattet das heißt angel gibt
uns vor dass wir trotzdem zehn prozent -
machen und er ist mit meinem privatleben
noch gar nicht inkludiert wie bezahle
ich dann mein privatleben um eine
private miete
ich weiß momentan noch nicht mal wie ich
mir übertrieben gesagt eine scheibe brot
kaufen soll und da bin ich nicht der
einzige
ich bin in kontakt mit 300 anderen
brautmoden leben und die auch die in der
branche mitarbeiten wir wissen alle
nicht mehr weiter was habe ich von
meinem fixkosten wenn zu hause aber
meine tiere verhungern und ich selber
hier ist so viel frust und ich habe mir
so viele fragen aufgeschrieben dafür
bräuchten der fas besonders sendung was
wünschen sie sich ganz konkret von der
politik was muss jetzt passieren
ich habe auf jeden fall eine
grundlegende frage auch an merkel
und zwar wir hatten eigentlich vor
sondern seit letztem jahr geplant dass
wir unseren laden deutlich weiter
ausbauen dass wir uns vergrößern
und dass wir auch eine gastronomische
fläche in dieser fläche mit anbieten so
eine art shop in shop prinzip
ich frage jetzt wirklich ein ernstes und
ich würde mir wünschen wenn irgendjemand
da auch eine antwort kriege ob er
wirklich diesen schritt
noch gehen sollten eine gastronomie zu
eröffnen oder ob es nicht weil so ist
macht aktuell in anschein wie einen
gastronomischen verbot kriegen weil man
könnte sich ja auch mit sämtlichen
mutation anstecken wenn wir da eine
antwort hätten wäre das sehr sehr toll
war es macht uns die planungssicherheit
dass wir einfach geld sparen indem da
keine gastronomie mehr planen und uns
nicht vergrößern sondern dass wir so
klein und süß bleiben und ich möchte
ganz gerne auch wissen was passiert im
winter 21 was passiert im winter 22
sämtliche mutation wir können doch nicht
jedes mal das unter schrauben wir müssen
unser altersheimen unserer alten leute
schützen definitiv dass er ein jahr
vergeigt ist einfach so aber lasst uns
jungen menschen noch leben wenn ich
hunger kriege ich liege wahrscheinlich
zu 99% einfach eine woche im bett
gemisch aus aber ich möchte meine
freunde sehen ich möchte meine freunde
immer wieder umarmt wir möchten auch mal
wieder ein steak essen gehen einfach nur
mal irgendwo hingehen und wenn ich dafür
meine beschreite maske tragen muss dann
ist das so dann ist das das was ich in
kauf nehmen
aber mir fehlt mein leben meine zukunft
meine arbeit mit fehlt einfach alles ich
kann nicht mehr
es heißt immer wir sollen uns
zusammenreißen er womit denn und was
soll ich denn zusammen reichen ich kann
nur zu hause sitzen und warten dass
irgendjemand was sagt übrigens damit mal
gute laune ihr dürfte für drei tage
was soll ich denn ich habe nichts was
ich machen kann nicht aber frau dasselbe
sie als letzte erzählen der runde last
but not least was wünschen sie sich von
der politik und was fordern sehen ja
tatsächlich dass die unterstützung da
ankommen wo sie auch dringend gebraucht
werden weil ich glaube auch dass weil
keine unterstützung angekommen fühlt man
sich halt auch im stich gelassen und und
und alleine gelassen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren